now the grandmother of a teenager killed
by police is calling for calm and an end
to the unrest that's gripped France over
the past five nights the 17 year old
known as nahil M was killed during a
police traffic stop outside Paris on
Tuesday sparking days of violent
protests the hell's grandmother says her
grandson's killing is being used as a
pretext for violence
I'm angry with the police officer who
my grandson and that's all I'm angry
with we have the police and lucky for us
that we have the police and the people
who are breaking things I told them stop
it stop it they're doing this with nail
as a pretext no people should stop they
should stop they should not break store
Windows they should not ransack schools
please don't break the cars the cars did
not do anything to you the school did
not do anything to you leave us alone
that's it I'm tired I can't bear this
any longer I no longer sleep and I even
turn off the TV I turned off everything
from Paris
the crisis meeting that president macron
convened with his interior Minister and
Justice Minister late on Sunday night
came up with four main solutions to work
on first of all that his ministers
continue to work to reduce the level of
violence that we've seen over the past
week here in France second of all a
recognition that there are underlying
issues that perhaps have been ignored in
the past but can be ignored no longer he
said there had to be a a reflection on
the causes of the unrest and the other
two points that came out of that crisis
meeting at the interior Minister
Ministry were that first of all the
finance ministry is going to work on
coming up with some kind of plan for
compensation and reparation for those
businesses that have been damaged by the
Looting of the past few days and and
also that the police are getting the
full support of the government for their
work trying to put down the unrest now
the big thing that has happened over the
weekend and I think it's really a
turning point in this whole crisis is
the intervention of Niall M's
grandmother and indeed one of the other
relatives who spoke to a different media
channel as well appealing for Khan I
think that's starting to really cut
through because as far as we've seen so
far on Sunday night there haven't been
any cases of serious unrest anywhere
we've been looking at social media we've
been scouring for video and that is
normally where we would see it appear
and we haven't seen anything so far and
the other thing is just the experience
of our own eyes here in central Paris
the police that we're standing next to
on the top of the champs-elysees say are
very relaxed very calm there's hardly
anybody on the streets at all there is a
group of motorcycle cops the highly
mobile Riot police that occasionally
Patrol past but even they appear to have
vanished in the past couple of hours so
it does appear that the tension is going
out of the out of the situation there is
cautious room for optimism that the
worst of this may have passed
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Central Paris